it's been on the mic I was talking about
oh I would have kicked you in the balls
ah somehow I would be a little turn on
my back I did have this friend who had a
friend who worked at like an S&M place
she just whipped guys for money and
apparently she got paid a lot and I was
like where can I get this job do you
Lauren that'd be so sexy if you did that
I feel like it'd be like pretty easy for
the amount of money that she was getting
paid why even give it a second thought
well I don't know how to get this job
yeah it's like hookers and there's like
rooms except then you don't have sex
with them you just beat them up dude if
you were a hooker I would totally buy
you no I'm not okay but if you were but
I'm not
I know but if he couldn't afford me what
do you mean how much would you charge a
lot what's a lot more than you could
afford what's that $10,000 you were
charged $10,000 yes someone to have sex
with you yeah Wow I'm worth it you
better be but I'd only last seconds and
that would be gone right away anyway
guys we're gonna watch the trailer
tonight for all cheerleaders die yay I
have no idea what this movie is about
but I'm excited to watch the trailer is
that Iowa's cheerleader for a really
long time and I've seen pictures yeah oh
yeah she was a sexy cheerleader back in
the day back in the day I'm not still
sexy are you like 36 no I'm just joking
Lauren okay yeah yeah [ __ ]
oh yeah we're gonna go watch this beer
she's gonna cat again Jane what is
happening all four of you died last
night
Wow oh she's magical
Lena's a [ __ ] that's not nice man you
shouldn't watch this for the girl what I
feel freaking fantastic today there's
only one outcome to keep you play dance
with me
they can't have
let's look sexy
come on children I'm gonna pee I want to
watch that silly Lions had done the
whole thing looks silly unless you look
silly and ridiculous but they're gonna
get a look a lot of guys like Ryan here
watching it because there's half-naked
girls running around yeah anything that
has to be yeah that's true
I am so poor from all those movies that
does look fine action like people asking
us to watch that yeah that looks like
wacky and sexy and a little scary and
violent I love that man yeah I'd like to
see a movie where like a girl's humping
a guy in and suddenly she bites into his
neck then he turns into that weird like
mummy thing yeah yeah that's hot maybe
that's where your jobs gonna be when
you're doing this and I'm fighting my
people and they turn into death there's
no work the point of that another thing
is that you're not actually like
physically touching them I don't know
how much a hugger cause I don't know how
much I'm sure they all range in price
one time I was doing online dating on
Craigslist or it could start with casual
encounters but then it was only guys on
there it's like every guy is just like
looking to get my dick sucked tonight
looking for some [ __ ] and then it's
just nothing but guideposts and the
girls ones are fake trust me I know
they're fake yeah some of them one of
them look for money but it was like $300
for the hour she looked good yeah I'll
chew those died I didn't want to say
that I'm disappointed in the opening
because the form of the basket toss is
not correct
I mentioned that I know I get really
upset I so know what you mean the TV
shows and movies where they have
cheerleaders uh-huh and it's so easy to
correct the form but for some reason
they never do they never do it also are
hiring professional cheerleaders and
dancers to be in these things so why
can't they do it right no I'm serious
I'm totally serious - no I'm being
serious stop mocking me but it's like
they don't care cuz I wasn't a thing
where I was a cheerleader than they also
hired dancers and the dancers serious
trauma for her back in cheerleading this
if you're new to the channel subscribe
why don't you stop we're gonna put it up
there to make it easier in my life y'all
put a tiny little button right here
do you make one big button that's the
entire screen yeah I used to done all
right yeah okay guys it's that important
time of the video that's near gun AR you
wanted me to flex my big muscles if that
wasn't like the madding Muslim yeah I
think it'd be better if you didn't I
have a muscle well you do have muscles
holy crap pumping iron with Lauren gah I
don't think we ever said our names I'm
Ryan
oh I'm Lauren yeah anyway near ago they
are shout out to you with Lauren's
awesome new biceps up now you just show
yours
yeah we okay d yeah yeah yes you can do
I have triceps again Oh where's my
triceps they're right here Lauren touch
right here yeah I feel it you can see it
right there hell yeah
all new guys to the channel are gonna
call me something mean I know it you
know talking about you guys comes to the
jello like what a homo jörgen I are
asked for the muscle [ __ ] you ask for
the muscle what we're just trying to
maybe he is don't say that I don't know
I have a lot of gay friends you know my
you know gay guys tend to be more
attracted to me than girls do maybe
that's a sign maybe I should try it out
sometimes they usually really like a
Posey that's like I'm pissed actual that
really there's trying to be cool I've
got a [ __ ] from a guy before do you
have to pay him no are you serious yeah
how is it it was nice
so then you have tried it are you guys
no I'm definitely not gay okay I tried
it I'm like this isn't for me yeah I was
curious that interesting mm-hmm you guys
learned a lot about
every day damn your gun you brought the
deep [ __ ] out of me man the way your
biceps are looks like you jack off on
your penis or something really good [ __ ]
if I had a penis I mean I guess like
technically like biologically the
clitoris clitoris is like a teeny tiny
penis yeah so you do have a tiny bit
thank you have a little tiny penis
that's how I'm always gonna be a
clitoris no I want to go down on tiny
penis I love that yeah I love your
clitoris too ha ha ha tie craft fits all
in caps oh it's tight he said uh give me
a shoutout
well here's your shower take it here
here get off my lawn happy Halloween
you're being so mean yeah I'm seeing him
like you know how my mom treats
trick-or-treaters like get the [ __ ] off
my property
or Hershey's kiss me you didn't like
trying that says we're out of candy and
then nobody wants come to your house we
have very misleading signs will be like
if you come to my house for candy you
will die and people think it's a
Halloween trick sounds like a Halloween
trick yeah I know but then people
actually end up dying cuz my mom's a
serial killer hi mom I know you watch
this channel every now and from prison
well so go to prison she's on the run
right now yes I haven't seen her in 10
years and I miss her a lot she's a good
mom remember when she used to make me
cereal in the morning tiger yeah crap
that's me giving you is my craft
signature movie thank you you have your
own signature move I mean like two
punches doesn't know a signature but
that's probably what people do actually
it's a lot to remember to do this
signature move you are welcome smiley
179 he wanted me to say shut up to my
main man tau wrong hey what's going on
Tyrone how come you want to shout out to
your friend and not to yet maybe his
name is Tyrone you know I'm saying maybe
or maybe you're just getting to
shoutouts for the price of one because
we're giving a shout-out to smiley 179
and to Tyrone it's nice being greedy
what the [ __ ] man is that what she's
doing
God despicable disgust me mm-hmm
I spit on you that's what I do yeah
let's not really do it long that's not a
nice camera
is it wrong to assume that Tyrone might
be black that's kind of racist but it
says shout out to my main man Tyrone
he's probably of african-american
descent yes we establish him in probably
every single video about how racist
right is everybody's a little bit racist
there's a song in a musical called
Avenue Q I'm not racist guy I just like
racist jokes so I'm not actually racist
see but you think that racist jokes are
funny because they're base and a little
bit of truth and that's why you think
they're funny what are you do you think
that it's true your psychoanalyzing me I
have plenty of different races of
friends why do you hate black people
I don't hate black people black people
they're my you know n-word with an A at
the end not an ER I hear that's okay
well you just say it and then we bleep
it out I'm too scared to eat it anyway
well a lot of people want the channel
have said you might end word to me yeah
and with their thumbnail on they look
like they're a black guy or they just
have a picture of a black guy yeah
they're not using their real picture
oh yeah it's true they just want to get
away with that work it's how you're
doing Tyrone I don't remember your
thumbnail it looks like but I'm assuming
that's what you're doing